so i really wanted to transform these
cookies into something that just screams
like
hey guys i'm katie and i've been a tasty
producer for the last three years and
today i'm going to talk about my first
viral tasty video sugar swirl cookies
these cookies are actually inspired by
my grandmother's sugar cookie recipe it
was the first recipe i ever learned how
to make and pretty soon i got really
good at it i was like 10 years old and
my family would start just requesting
them on like a week weeknight
and it was really the first recipe i
ever memorized like i just could whip it
up didn't even need to look at a
card
when i first saw that this video was
going viral i was so happy because i
think i felt like i put my heart out
there i brought some part of my family
with me and that's really what gave me
the success
and i think when you do something
authentic and genuine and something you
really feel passionate about people
always respond to that
and it felt good to have the affirmation
that other people were enjoying
something that my grandmother had made
and my family had enjoyed and now the
whole internet was enjoying it too
but i also was so excited that other
people
found it approachable and it made their
holidays joyful and that makes me really
happy anyone who works at tasty or knows
me in my life knows that i am absolutely
obsessed with the holidays i love all
the decorations i love dressing up i
love giving presents i'm just obsessed
and i love like making food and hosting
gatherings cookies are one of my
favorite things about the holidays
because it's such an excellent way to
express yourself every year my aunt
makes a bucket of different cookies that
she gives out to everyone in the family
and that's the thing i'm more excited
about than any present i get is just
this bucket of cookies and then everyone
gets their own and we're all fighting
over it and we're like nobody take
cookies out of my bucket and it's it's
really special to me i actually got her
permission to use my grandma's recipe
before i was like altering it for this
video because cookies are sacred in my
family what i really love about these
cookies is how customizable they are and
that you can use them for any holiday it
could be halloween it could be st
patrick's day which is my birthday but i
just love that you can use any sprinkles
or color to just make it celebrate
whatever you want to celebrate
my number one tip for this recipe is to
make sure you chill that dough for the
four hours because this is a slice and
bake you really want to make sure that
it's got its shape and it's holding well
and putting it in the fridge is gonna
help guarantee that you get these
perfect circles when you slice it one of
the trickiest parts of this recipe is
rolling the two sheets of dough together
if you're in a really hot kitchen you
can put one of the sheets in the fridge
while you prep the other this will make
it easier when you go to roll up your
dough
let the plastic wrap help you get that
first
swirl so you get a really tight circle
you want to start strong and end strong
oh yes
[Music]
you